hi in this video we would be talking
about membrane potential of a neuron and
also how membrane potential for neuron
is important in terms of its physiology
and its circuit properties so neuron is
very different from a normal cell a
normal cell has a membrane and neuron
also has a membrane but the neurons
membrane is charged and white is charged
we would get to know this in this video
so if you think about a patch of
membrane and then we try to think about
what is the source of the membrane
potential we would clearly understand
across the membrane there is uneven
distribution of several ionic species
such as calcium sodium or potassium and
their concentration is not equal on the
both side and this difference in charge
separation is actually the source of the
membrane potential now why there is the
difference between the charge we'll get
to know in this video so if we talk
about the forces across the membrane by
there then there is one type of force is
electrical force and this electrical
force is f equal to Q into DV DX which
DV DX is the potential gradient now why
there is a difference between charges
across both the sides because several
ions has several different
permeabilities so always and sometimes
the concentration of ions in one side of
the membrane versus other side of the
membrane is different so already there
is a concentration gradient established
so there is a chemical force due to
concentration gradient and there is an
electrical force due to charge
separation and all these forces are
working across the membrane now this is
talk about a simple situation for
example we consider there is a potassium
ion or any cation like that so this
cation can move into the inside the cell
if the membrane potential is negative so
if the membrane potential drops from
zero millivolts to minus 90 milli volt
the internal situation would be negative
in that situation it would attract the
iron right imagine a situation where the
membrane potential rise from zero
millivolt to plus 20 millivolt in that
situation the internal side gets
positive and at that kind of situation
whenever the potassium ion would try to
get inside it would face a repulsion so
depending upon the membrane potential
and the charge on the membrane the ionic
mobility is also altered now also the
force forces due to chemical gradient
exist because for example if we talk
about potassium ion potassium ion is
present inside the cell in 150 milli
molar x' whereas outside of the cell the
concentration is only 5 to 5 to 10
millimolar so there is a gradient which
is existing from inside to the outside
now we'll talk about a terminology which
is called as a reversal potential
reversal potential for any particular
ion is a potential at which there is no
net ionic movement and it is different
for different ion so since we are
talking about the potassium in this
video let's talk about potassium so we
have we know this potassium has a
concentration gradient from inside to
the outside of the cell and there is
always electrical gradient so it's its
reversal potential is calculated
according to this formula and it turns
out if you plug in the values of its
concentration inside versus outside you
would get a reversal potential of minus
90 millivolt so that that means is at
minus 90 millivolt the force is due to
electrical field and forces due to
chemical gradient both balance each
other and as a result there is no net
movement of this particular ion so at
this particular particular voltage there
is no movement of potassium ion and it
is called reversal potential of the
potassium now membrane potential is very
important in terms of neural physiology
because how quickly the neuron can fire
how the neuron can interpret the signal
in the environment it all depends upon
the resting membrane potential and we
can measure the resting membrane
potential using patch clamp recording if
you don't know how patch clamp recording
work you can watch my video in the
neurobiology playlist so the resisting
moment potential is determined by two
factors first the difference in ionic
concentration and secondarily
permeability of these concentration now
if we talk about a neuronal membrane
there are several different ion channels
there are sodium channels which would
bring sodium from outside to inside
there are chloride channels which would
allow chloride from outside to inside
and there is potassium channel we shall
leak potassium channels which would
allow for a leak diffusion of the
potassium from inside to outside and
there are voltage-gated potassium
channels according to the voltage it
opens or closes there are also sodium
potassium ion exchange pump which pumps
which which pumps ion based on the ATP
now here are the extracellular and
intracellular concentration of sodium
chloride and potassium ions and
depending upon that you can clearly
understand from which direction the ions
would move and here is how sodium
potassium and exchange pump work so it
would pump sodium ions out and it would
pump potassium ions in and as a result
there is the net charge which is
building upon in the cell is basically
negative because there are more amount
of sodium ions going out but less amount
of positive charge is coming in now
also the leak potassium channels are
always active so a lot of positive
charge are going out in the cell while
the cell interesting situation that is
why the cells resting membrane potential
is always minus 70 millivolts and it
could be calculated using goldman
Hodgkin and cards equation in this
equation you plug in all the reversal
potential values of several ions which
are present in across the cell and you
end up getting a overall membrane
potential value of minus 70 millivolts
so when the neurons is not firing it is
in a resting state its membrane
potential is minus 70 millivolts and
during action potential this minus 70
millivolts fold edge changed to a
reversal change towards the reversal
potential of sodium becomes more
positive and that is how the action
potential is fired so action potential
is nothing but Delta change in the
membrane potential now the importance of
resting membrane potential for example a
neuron has very low resting membrane
potential let's say it has a resting
membrane potential is minus 85 versus a
neuron which has a resting membrane
potential minus 65 so you can clearly
understand which neuron would responds
fast in in terms of stimulus let's say
the neuron 1 which has less resting
membrane potential or minus 85 millivolt
it would be harder for that neuron to
fire an action potential and the
strength of the stimulus this may need
to find an action potential would be big
right whereas the neuron which has a
membrane potential of minus 65
millivolts which is lot more positive
than the normal situation it would
require a very small impulse to generate
an action potential so how quick the new
one would fire how many action
potentials would it would fire or how
easily it would fire it all depends upon
resting membrane potential now very
recent research also shows that not only
resting membrane potential is important
for a mature neuron it is also important
for neuronal progenitors depending upon
the resting membrane potential and the
depolarize state it turns out the
progenitor decides what to become
whether or nude on and where it need to
migrate so all these properties are
determined by resting membrane potential
so rescue movement potential is a so and
so much important property for a neuron
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you